i am ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
reasons to see where we're going to give
you reasons to see and maybe not to see
Riddick so let's go some people reason
is see number one Vin Diesel
this is the first verdict movie i watch
it same here yeah and I kind of want to
watch the other ones now but yeah
Riddick was pretty [ __ ] cool in this
movie and he's a rock did you I went in
and I was like I'm not really all that
interested in this I wasn't really even
aware when the other ones came out and I
saw this and I was like it doesn't seem
like you would talk about it Rick movie
without immediately talking about Vin
Diesel cuz he's awesome he's got just
the right amount of charisma I gotta say
for a first Riddick movie I was little
lost in the beginning I was like I see a
god what it what is going on here is a
little little confusing but honestly I
understood like ninety-five percent of
the movie and anything that harks back
to the other movies they pretty much
give you at least enough to go on first
main chunk is just him alone on this
planet and there's some voiceover
narrations yeah almost like a weird
sci-fi film noir thing I you know as
time went on I was getting more and more
invested in this guy I mean this guys
supposed to be sort of like a ninja buff
is [ __ ] we were way who's got like a
sarcastic personality and he makes it
very believable it's not just some guy
stepping in doing some action scenes
like this requires some acting and he
does a really good job in it when he's
alone you get to know in one way and
then he's pitted against other people
you kind of get two sides of that
character because you kind of really
like him when he's alone and then later
on in the movie he's got that more sort
of sarcastic kind of I'll do whatever I
have to sort of edge comes out he's
pretty funny in the role too it was
pretty funny he's funny yeah he's pretty
badass yeah kind of scary times kinda
scary makes me want to like [ __ ] kick
some ass yeah but would be really quiet
so no one can tell yeah until their ass
is already been yeah that's a sensitive
part of this movie is like people's
asses get has them and you don't even
see it a lot of the type of a reason to
see number two supporting cast the
supporting cast is really good i
especially like what's a character's
name Sal oh it's uh it's santana santana
cell so this this guy they introduce
them like oh he's the evil you know
scary one of the good with it
think of a joke as the movie progresses
yeah and he's a really fun to watch I
thought he was great you know he every
time he was on screen he was he was like
the most entertaining one out of the
bunch it blends in well at the same time
you don't like him just enough but you
like him just enough for certain scenes
to work not everyone's is over the top
but everyone is believable within the
world well there's a certain kind of
cheese going on about your performances
you know yeah like I don't [ __ ] guys but
I [ __ ] up guys sometimes or whatever
however the [ __ ] line goes with
lesbian said ya know it's like you get
this a like super machismo thing that's
going on with all the characters but in
two shades you know it's like no
everyone's in the same movie still and
everyone you know has a personality it's
all colorful you know Robert Forrester's
really good in this movie too he sounds
a lot like him yeah the guy pleased with
johns johns he plays johns sup
jeremyjahns so the guy plays John's runs
do a lot of robert forster he's really
good in the movie too there's this woman
who I wish they'd used more of in the
film not the black woman they kill her
off really early yeah and that's a
really sinister moment when ya he's
untying her because it's just a couple
lines of dialogue you get an awful sense
for what she has been there yeah it's
like oh my god what is happen to you
lady yeah and then BAM just a four way
to go out and apply that we never learn
about a little bit unless we learned it
in previous spoiler alert about somebody
whose name you don't even learn there's
one character in the supporting cast to
kind of annoy me a little bit and I
think was really the acting of the guy
who is the one they called the kid the
whole time he's like a very wooden
performance to me and I didn't really
like the whole imp rainer god christian
stuff for some reason is like it just
didn't fit for me yeah his characters
didn't like everybody gets one thing
could he got that the camper didn't a
set like why is he there if he's like
mr. Christian guy yeah what are you a
mercenary it didn't make any sense to me
reason to see number three the sci-fi
what I love about this is it's a real
science fiction film when you see the
trailer you think you're just going to
get some like action flick but no this
is like a real science fiction world
we're living in and all of it
I loved it it was it was so it's it's
what movies are made of you know just
pure fiction you know to piggyback off
that's like you see the trailer and I'm
thinking like okay you know we're gonna
have Riddick squirt off lots of crazy
monsters and stuff and you do get some
of that but part of what I enjoyed so
much is that it's a different side of
sci fi for a lot of the movie you know
it's just sort of exploring a strange
world and there's lots of cool designs
and stuff like that yeah and I kept
finding myself noticing and I'm not like
a you know science genius but every
creature and every gadget and stuff
everything seemed to be designed in a
way where I was like yeah I get these
choices like that this is how that bike
works and I can see how a creature would
evolve you know there was just little
attention to details and stuff like that
but they were awesome in a very science
fictiony sort of way I think it's broken
up into three parts the like the first
the Viper stack the second like the
first 20 to 30 minutes it's pretty much
just Vin Diesel carrying the whole thing
by himself and playing off science
fiction creatures then like the second
part is like the hunt for Riddick and
there's not much Riddick you see but
it's cool how they do that I think the
guys are there hunting the whole time
and you're barely seeing you you got to
know the first 20 minutes and you it's
like what you said earlier it's like a
different side of him and then in the
third part it's like pitch black you
miss them too yeah yeah exactly and it's
it's it's it's a one transition to the
next yeah like a blend of it it's not to
necessarily how the trailer leaves you'd
believe which which I was psyched about
it is just feeling like it doesn't feel
super modern either in a cool way
because it felt kind of like somebody
really beefed up like some kind of 90s
sci-fi action flick and brought it back
because it has that sort of it's like a
really well-made sci-fi channel movie
and you gotta admit it's like is you got
original content in here and at the end
of day it's also meant just mainly
entertain get would be it's simple and
immediate but it's still fun and there's
still lots of action there's still lots
of effects and stuff like that don't
take it like I'm saying this movie has
like the most depth no it's not super
self-important you know what there's a
former thing that can be but there's
enough in there to make you go like yeah
this is science fiction Yeah right
reason to see number 4 effects
I like this movie's affects a lot cuz
these a lot of practical effects at
first there's a lot of CG and I was like
this this doesn't look the most
believable to me yeah bad but but you
can tell with a lot of the creatures and
stuff like that there are things that
you can kind of tell are not the
greatest cg but for some reason it works
you know it seems like they only use
things as necessary because you have the
cg animals and stuff like that but you
also have a lot of practical effects
it's really correct well that effects
are so cool or some movie boss and I'm
so glad this was an armor ate a movie
yeah it does yeah honestly like there's
some very like there's not a lot of
action but there's some violent moments
and the practical effects on them are
very fun yeah and there's also some
stuff that looks like it was probably
animatronic or puppeteering yeah so like
it does really seem like nobody got lazy
with the effects on this one even if the
process isn't like the green screens and
stuff aren't always perfect you still
believe the world in the world is still
really cool to look at reason see number
five the action um action however the
action too well actually there's a
little bit of a didn't walk away
thinking about the action thought about
like all the other cool stuff right yeah
but there is some really sweet there
there are some sweet it's not even so
much action sequences they're just sweet
action moments and Vin Diesel [ __ ]
rocks over the action man it does he
doesn't just drive cars no no no he can
drive a space bike hey cajeta space he
can use a little bone sword he can steal
woman's makeup products very efficiently
smart yeah yeah I was really cool how he
did that to the vin diesel's just so
badass like he is the action pretty much
it's like whenever he steps in the frame
it's just like he is in action yeah cuz
he's cool it's not just cuz he's like
some buff guy like he's just yes Riddick
that's the reason to see this movie and
he is the action yeah there's moments
where he's just saying dialogue and it's
so [ __ ] cool the way he does it yeah
that it is like watching an action speak
dialogue is in the action yeah to me all
the action felt like super merited by
the story so they didn't so much come
across
Shin scenes is just like sequences in
which he had to figure things out and
then fight stuff well exactly like I was
ever watching the action going out oh
cool action you know like they didn't
try being flashy about it they kept it
grounded in a certain world where you're
not thinking action scene okay you know
what I mean yeah and that one shot
that's all over the trailers where he
like it's also a body shot a clerk it
that's like the only time anything like
that like really indulgently action II
like that happens you know there's well
no memory he's the bike to set a couple
aliens on final school yeah but it was
pretty [ __ ] and what it is actually
it's still like sweet sweet yeah love it
yeah yeah it's like appropriately
violence so that you don't need tons of
overdrawn action scenes pleasing to see
number six cinematography and directing
the cinematography is excellent is
awesome it is incredible it has a lot of
your favorite shots I do love Dutch
angles man the cinematography and this
is so neat in the way how it complements
the story so well because as this film
progresses from first to second a third
act the cinematography changes along
with it and it's it's so just wonderful
and i'm sure the director had a couple
of shots that he that he said he wanted
to end he did a good job one directing
it's like it seems like it's
appropriately directed it's not any more
or less than it ought to be and yeah
like this guy really seemed like he knew
what simple story he wanted to tell like
so many of these movies get like
overblown with visuals or overblown
we're trying to be fancy about something
and this guy you know it's like he
didn't try to be fancy and it was fancy
it was fancy i'm in the right moments
like it was it was really really well
directed and cinematography really well
risen to see number seven the dog roof
the side of lassie our show is it yes
yeah she's right over throw me over
cranky that's all I want to see the the
Scooby Gang and the mystery machine in
the next yeah the dog at first I was
like they're putting a lot of focus on
this dog for some reason and
eventually you're like that dog I like
this dog Alana you know the dog is it
you know it's a CG creation but they
make you love it it's perfect because
you see how weird it interacts with
people it's like some sarcastic [ __ ]
and you see how he is with a dog and
it's like you still a little bit of an
[ __ ] buddies is you see a much more
sweet side to the guy much more charming
sides of the guy he does a good job is
this a science pizza is a fake dog and
he's bouncing off in exhibits real you
know I wonder if they motion captured a
real doll like found a way to do that
yeah because they did these little
nuance II think we're like the dogs
trying to play with them and they just
let the dog be a dog yeah cuz you know
like when I first time you see the dog
it's like a CG but then eventually it's
like you stop thinking about that and
yeah because the behavior it's like yeah
that really bothered to be like you know
this is how a dog would want to play and
they just let the dog be a dog for a few
scenes which is really fun damn good dog
in this film man you know and then last
thing you thought you were gonna hear us
say yeah reasons not to see some super
convenient plot points yeah it's a
cheesy film yeah you know those shoots
gonna happen we're like pretty
convenient if you didn't even really
bother me I just feel like we ought to
at least address it like the second half
of the movie is really possible because
of one very dumb decision then there are
little things along the way where you're
like oh that that was convenient you
know because it was there for some
reason so you know there are certain
things like that that helped to move the
plot along so it's not a perfect script
by any means you know like the
convenience II stuff when it happened it
didn't know I me but eventually I just
get pulled back into the movie again
it's not like a reason not to see the
movie sort of like just you know be
aware and don't do that thing where
you're watching a movie where most of
its good and fine like a little thing
wrong with it then you walk out talking
about that great Dallas movies it's just
too convenient and then I have you have
like two examples to use in that's it
you know in a movie trying to be much
more serious and much more
self-important you know then it would be
worth you know getting frustrated over
but for what this movie is supposed to
be you know it's it's a it's a really
well-done b-movie yeah there's some
flaws like um I think I think sometimes
the swear words are
a little out of place in this movie
sometimes I feel like they just
interjected the f-word yes interjected
there are some times where you believe
the sort of macho lines and there are
other times where you're like you just
wanted to put a much alive yeah that
seems that sounds like a writer right
yeah exactly it's like they're there are
some times when they flip-flop between
us is the character or you being funny
like yeah and you know like I thought it
dragged a tiny bit but not really like
it's not like the movies good and it's
like ones is gonna end it's like early
on I I thought okay this is going a
little slow but once it gets picked up
it it is picked up it and they are on
that giant I can they are rolling like
how future bikes are still a pain yeah
yeah jerilyn from let's kill me vin
diesel can make this look cool yeah well
because he has a very well he kind of
looks like a darebin me he looks like
that yeah he kind of has a ver mana has
like this bear thing yeah he does look
like a barrier right I never thought
about now like his nose is kind of broad
and yeah you smile yeah a little beige
looks like a like a cuddly bear but it
barely yeah he'd be a good dad Ryan's
consensus a great sci-fi time with Vin
Diesel is the reason to see Riddick a
great sci-fi time with Vin Diesel is a
reason to see Rick yeah I love sci-fi
and I love Vin Diesel in this movie and
I've never loved in diesel before but I
love him now Sherri's consensus b-movie
sci-fi fun is the reason to see Riddick
feet movie sci-fi fun is the reason to
see Riddick you know like I said it's
like a really well done 90s SQ no sci-fi
channel movie alright guys checking out
a review for Riddick why don't you go
ped school that comment box below and
tell us which one is your favorite out
of the Riddick trilogy yeah then once
you're done doing that why don't you
come over here click on this little
button so you can see more episodes of
reasons to see then what you're doing
that and then you're done with it click
this button to follow us on Twitter and
like us on Facebook like us once you're
done with that once you're done prove
the
you like us because you're going to want
to get updated with new videos and
reviews every week if you do like us and
if so click here on the subscribe button
button yeah subscribe really tripped
over that one this week yeah or else
we're gonna ghost you mother [ __ ] yeah
I wish Vin Diesel said the [ __ ]
line just once ghost you I'm gonna go
see mother that's what killing people is
in this movie then it's ghosting them
yeah that's cool that's really cool yeah
you're really seeing someone yeah that's
a that's not a phrase they came up with
I don't know if they came up with it
original but I've heard it before like
I've heard it oh yeah and he started
using it I'll ghost you how people can
though was that mean it's a [ __ ] kill
you yeah and they'll be like whoa that
that wasn't funny and I'll be like I'm
sorry across the line I think you need
to be in the right environment you know
so you either have to be in space or
like in the ghetto yeah yeah with all my
black friends
you